ce printemps ils se sont improvisés
jardinier acrobates ou athlètes dans la
ruelle
mais aujourd'hui la famille d'isabelle
marjorie tremblay commence à avoir hâte
de quitter la ville surtout qu'à la
famille ils ont l'habitude de réserver
leurs voyages d'été j'ai rapidement à
cabin fever disons que je peux pas
imaginer être ni à la maison ni même à
montréal pendant tout l'été
personnellement je suis une adepte de
contrées sauvages mc les grandes revues
je sais qu'on a ce potentiel est ici au
québec me disais c'est l'occasion à
connaître plus une de ses options une
semaine d'aventuré avec les caravaniers
une entreprise d'ici qui habituellement
organise des séjours de randonnée kayak
ou d'alpinisme dans des destinations
exotiques
son fondateur richard immiscé vite
ajusté ça répond très bien présentement
cet été il propose une quinzaine de
forfait au québec de la mistassibi au
nord du lac-saint-jean l'abitibi pour
les lacs
évidemment les forfaits de kayak sur le
fleuve ça va de soi
l'algérie via zone boréale aussi où on
voit un peu plus haut ces groupes sont
d'une dizaine de personnes et plusieurs
départs affiche complet si dans les
crises faut trouver les opportunités en
voilà une formidable de montrer aux
québécois qu'ils ont et territoires
fantastique et que ça vaut la peine de
payer pour ce maintenant avec la réponse
ça fait à peine une semaine que c'est
lancé j'ai pas de deux les québécois
comprennent que oui ça vous le rappelle
parmi les gagnants de l'été il y à aussi
bien sur les piscines leurs ventes au
québec sont en hausse de 15 à 40 % par
rapport à l'année dernière selon les
entreprises à qui nous avons parlé mais
le besoin de partir ce sera là une
fausse
ça fait deux semaines pour lui dans
notre piscine seul ou abandonner le tour
de notre jardin notre cour est belle
mais c'est important d'être des peas
c'est dans les vacances y eu énormément
de bien fait ali ailleurs marc antoine
vacheron ajoute que la rentabilité voire
la survie de nombreuses entreprises
dépendra des touristes québécois cet été
les chiffres qui sortent actuellement
c'est des tiers donc on jusqu'à un tiers
vont rester à la maison
un tiers ne prendront pas de vacances et
un tiers vont prendre des vacances à
l'extérieur de leur maison
sauf que ça paraît peu mais comparé aux
chiffres d'il ya un mois
c'est le double des vacances qui pour
plusieurs se feront sur deux roues le
vélo lui aussi sera un succès de l'été
les vendeurs font des affaires en or
certains disent même qu'ils vont être en
rupture de stock qui va leur manquer de
vélo à vendre surtout pour les enfants
donc ça c'est des signes indéniables
vélo québec s'attend donc à ce que les
excursions d'une ou de plusieurs
journées soit très populaire on a déjà
un réseau de voies cyclables à travers
le québec
ce soit des voies urbaines que ce soit
la route verte qui dépassent les dix
mille kilomètres c'est plus que
n'importe où ailleurs au canada et en
amérique du nord dont la culture à lille
[Musique]
une location familiale à 2000 $ par
semaine
de nombreux québécois qui ont l'argent
nécessaire décide cet été et d'opter
pour le véhicule récréatif vr saint cyr
un des gros concessionnaires dans la
province vend et loue beaucoup de
roulotter de caravanes depuis quelques
semaines
vu les circonstances c'est une façon de
voyager qui de plus en plus sécuritaires
ou aux yeux des gens donc ça nous donne
quand même une bonne engouement un
marché qui devient profitable pour nous
l'objectif des familles c'est d'être
autonome d'avoir cette autonomie au sein
d'un même véhicule c'est extrêmement
populaire et c'est clair que c'est une
avenue qui nous ouvre des possibilités
comme touristes chose certaine les
activités en nature et les locations de
chalets auront la cote sont voit ce qui
se passe en france où il est incertain
déconfinement ya des mesures qui sont
prises par exemple il ya 48 heures de
repos entre deux entre deux locations
isabelle comme bien des vacanciers comme
toute l'industrie attend avec impatience
le plan touristique du gouvernement nous
regarder toutes les options de location
chalets du camping de lui une vente par
exemple mais on ne sait pas encore ce
qui est permis que ce qui est permis
elle espère pouvoir se déplacer d'une
région à l'autre bientôt et attend la
décision de québec
on a vraiment des paysages
spectaculaires on est reconnu à travers
le monde pour ça et puis nous ici on en
profite peut-être pas assez alors c'est
vraiment l'occasion de le faire cet été
puis on en convient le trim
nombre d'entreprises souhaitent un vrai
début de saison à la saint jean baptiste